we found another guy with tears in his
eyes Republican senator Lindsey Graham
who has debased himself humiliatingly
over the last six years
was tearing up on Fox news last night it
does not get much better than this here
is Lindsay crying about Trump's
indictment
wow
how do you do it you take a well if you
got a pile of crap and you chop it up 34
times it's still a pile of crap it's
duplicious charging I think by
duplicious he meant means duplicitous or
duplicative
it's very unclear what he's talking
about but he is all teary a pile of crap
is duplicious charging they're trying to
smear the guy they're trying to take
cases that nobody else would take and
resurrect them this is literally legal
Voodoo folks
I really hope that this is the first of
many indictments I really do if Lindsay
is this broken up and triggered by the
first one which is arguably the most
minor one what's happening in Georgia is
potentially far more disastrous for
Trump than this just you wait until we
get to the next one so Lindsay not
having a good one let's briefly talk now
about Eric Trump